I also want to be clear that I don't  think there's anything wrong with men  managing women it is a business at the  end of the day and a lot of the times in  my opinion I think men manage businesses  very well however when you are managing  a business of this nature where of  course it's sexual then again play  stupid games when you see the prices  there are going to be consequences  people are going to say things about you  whether they're true or whether they're  absolutely my advice to women is always  never get involved in any of these  things preserve your value don't show  your body off to the world I think it's  kind of disgusting to be honest and I  think it's also very unhealthy mentally